ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Can you
get a sense of Google Cloud
Platform data processing
and data storage products
in just a few minutes?
Let's find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It all starts with the ability
to store objects or files.
Google Cloud Storage is a
fully-managed object storage
service.
It offers different storage
classes for multi-regional,
for optimal and user
latency, to coldline storage
for lower frequency access.
There is a single unified API
to interact with cloud storage.
This makes, for
instance, moving objects
across storage classes
completely seamless.
Cloud storage offers
strong consistency,
and is designed for 11
lines of durability.
Storing data is great,
but processing it
is probably even more useful.
In the big data category,
a GCP "hello world"
would be to throw an SQL query
at a large set of data, hoping
to find useful insights.
Let's do just that
with BigQuery.
You could, of course, upload
and work with your own data set,
but here we will use sample data
from a public data set instead.
What's important here
is that at no point
do you need to provision a
cluster or storage capacity.
Simply craft a
standard SQL query,
and within seconds,
BigQuery will
have processed potentially
gigantic amounts of data
and produced a result that can
be saved in various formats.
For instance, using the
public data set of GitHub
commits, here we've
asked BigQuery
to provide the list of
the top Google employees
fixing stuff on GitHub.
Also with the same data
set, we can figure out
which programming languages
make developers the most happy.
Notice the regular expression
embedded in the query.
The key point here is how
much data is processed
in such a short period of time.
You can import or stream data
to BigQuery using an API,
but also export just
about any data produced
by other GCP products
and services,
such as logs to BigQuery.
If you have existing Apache
Hadoop or Spark workloads,
you will likely be
interested in trying out
Cloud Dataproc, GCP's
fully-managed environment that
will spin up a cluster
in less than 90 seconds.
Let's talk about relational
databases, or RDBMSes SQL
as a language still has
unsurpassed qualities,
and RDBMSes, such as MySQL and
PostgreSQL are very popular.
This is why Google
Cloud SQL is a managed
service that supports both of
these relational databases.
This is a great
solution for storing
your existing or new
application data.
Simply choose between
MySQL and PostgreSQL.
Select a machine size with up
to hundreds of gigabytes of RAM
and terabytes of storage.
Select a zone, and
cloud SQL will take care
of providing the following--
encryption at rest
and in transit,
a private IP address,
data replication
between multiple zones
with automatic failover,
automated backups, as well
as point-in-time recovery.
Staying with
relational databases,
Google also offers
Cloud Spanner,
a horizontally scalable,
strongly consistent
relational database
as a service.
Make sure to check out this
truly innovative technology
that defies the CAP theorem and
that many Google services are
built on.
In the NoSQL department,
Cloud Firestore
is a highly scalable,
strongly consistent database
offering two modes--
the native mode offering
real time updates
and offline support
for mobile developers,
and the datastore mode
for backend developers
looking for a schema-less
documents database.
Cloud Bigtable will complement
your storage options
with the petabyte
scale fully managed,
no escrow database service.
This will be mostly suited
for large analytical and
operational workloads as it
comes with high throughput
characteristics such as
consistent sub-10 millisecond
latency.
In any case, you should visit
cloudatgoogle.com/storageoptions
for a decision tree to
understand which is the best
database for you.
GCP has numerous other
data-related products,
some particularly innovative.
Be sure to consider
the following.
Pub/Sub for producing
and consuming messages
globally across all
GCP zones and regions.
Filestore for applications that
require a system interface.
Cloud Memorystore
for Redis provides
a fully managed, in-memory
data storage service
that is ideal to
build application
caches with sub-millisecond
data access.
Cloud Dataflow to
build and execute
unified batch and
streaming pipelines
using the Apache Beam
programming model.
Dataprep to make sure
your data scientists
are not spending 90% of
their time cleaning up data
instead of processing it.
And Data Studio, for interactive
dashboards and engaging
reports.
Consider taking free codelabs
linked in the description below
to explore any of
these GCP products.
Check out the compute overview
and machine learning episodes,
and look forward to an upcoming
video on DevOps and tooling.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
and share.
See you soon for another
GCP Essentials video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]